buongiorno a tutti carlo ratti contento
di essere con voi oggi ed ex volevo
raccontarvi in questi pochi minuti un po
delle ricerche che facciamo partendo
proprio da dall'idea di design e come il
design ma design inteso in un'accezione
anglosassone design che mette insieme
anche matematica e scienza della
complessità eccetera può aiutarci a
ripensare le nostre città
allora condivido adesso lo schermo
[Applauso]
dovreste vederlo fa o un secondo quello
che vediate lo schermo adesso era una
partita queste queste sono delle visioni
del danno 2000 televisione del xix
secolo della del 1890 dal 1899 1910 di
un gruppo di artisti francesi è solo
riguardiamo oggi vediamo che in alcuni
casi ci hanno azzeccato ad esempio
all'epoca immaginarono gira in anticipo
la meccanizzazione dell'agricoltura e
che insomma un po di queste macchine e
di questa automazione effettivamente
arrivata predissero anche una specie di
rumba ante litteram rumba al piccolo
robot che pulisce nostre case che come
lo immaginare un la fine dell'ottocento
però in altri casi non ci azzeccano per
niente ad esempio pensavano che noi ci
saremmo spostati nei nostri mari in
questo modo oppure che la polizia si
sarebbe avrebbe occupato i cieli le
nostre città in questo modo una visione
che anche per per insomma per coloro che
si entusiasmano il pensiero di trony
dappertutto è ancora molto lontana dalla
realtà
beh perché vengo poi se con questo
perché i privacy
il futuro è un problema inerente molto
legato al progetto progetto viene da
proietti per viene pensare al domani e e
come dice karl popper il grande filosofo
della scienza austriaco il futuro è
aperto non è predeterminato e per questo
motivo non possiamo non può essere pre
li scopre prevedere se non vai a xvi
depresso non per caso e le possibilità
che presenti nel futuro sono infinite e
che c'è il futuro e qualcosa
perché in qualche modo costruiamo tutti
insieme costruiamo col designer e questa
un'altra frase una frase di albert simon
bersani il premio nobel nel secolo
passato grande ricercatore anche
matematico e ed economista in belgio
simon in questo libro è molto bello di
scienze dell'artificiale dice le scienze
naturali si occupano delle cose così
come sono
mentre nel design progettazione si
occupa delle cose del mondo così come
potrebbe
potrebbe essere ecco allora come vuole
fare ridere alcuni esempi di design che
permane su un design sono esempi in cui
sono molte matematica che usano molto
molti pit età molti il mondo dei dati
insomma che usano strumenti di questo
tipo
però in fondo per rispondere a domande
di design design in questa accezione
come versandoci domande legate proprio
alla progettazione e alla trasformazione
della città per esempio le cooperative
parte è legato intimamente a una
trasformazione oggi in corso alle nostre
città che è quello del digitale negli
ultimi anni internet è diventato
internet james l'internet delle cose
potremmo dire che internet è entrato
nelle nostre città e quindi ci permette
di raccogliere moltissimi dati il mondo
di pictet a urbano quindi di capire
meglio le nostre città e di conseguenza
di progettarle meglio oggi per esempio
possiamo vedere una città in questo modo
questa e lisbona sembra quasi un
organismo vivente lisbona matata usando
miliardi di punti raccolti dal sistema
di mobilità urbana
questa una visualizzazione l'altro di
pedro cruz pedro è stato un ricercatore
nel nostro gruppo al al mit boston
avesse professore alla northeastern
university e questa visualizzazione
anche al moma museo d'arte moderna di
new york per dirvi 5 10 20 anni fa era
difficile visualizzare una città in modo
dinamico come come vediamo qui oggi sta
diventando invece invece possibile
insomma che questi dati 20 anni fa non
esistevano oggi ci permettono di leggere
il mondo in cui viviamo come un
organismo vivente
e se poi usiamo questi dati questa
grande quantità di dati questa grande
mole di dati che appunto i beta per fare
analisi possiamo scoprire cose
interessanti in questo caso siamo
partiti dati simili queste sono dati dei
taxi nella città di new york poi vedete
ogni puntino un budino giallo e un pick
up qualcuno che sale sul taxi un puntino
blu purtroppo qualcuno che scende da un
taxi questo è il rapporto dj sky a new
york se sommate fuori cercherà qua in
basso a destra nell'immagine vedete
manhattan manhattan e poi tutti i
quartieri di new york è una domanda che
ho iniziato a farci su questi dati i
dati che abbiamo ottenuto è già un po di
anni fa è stata di quei due punti a new
york a manhattan beta quei due punti
avete centinaia di migliaia di
spostamenti e taxi che che li collegano
nel corso dell'anno
ci siamo chiesti quanti di questi
spostamenti sarebbero condivisibili da
più di una persona cioè sarebbe
possibile come 14 capitato mentre siamo
in un albergo new york di andare ad
esempio di andare all'aeroporto
e mentre lo aspettiamo taxi c'è qualcun
altro di fianco a noi che sta andando
nello stesso aeroporto e avremmo potuto
condividere la stessa macchina lo stesso
veicolo però di dollari ma da quanti
veicoli potrebbero essere condivisi per
analizzare questo sembrati da questa
grande mole di dati abbiamo analizzati
matematicamente con un metodo che
abbiamo chiamato sherbini t mac cloni
grati di condivisione poi vedete
l'articolo in cui in cui ha sviluppato
il metodo per chi volesse tutti gli
articoli sono disponibili sul sul nostro
sito del laboratorio quindi trovate
l'intero testo da scaricare
come vedete un pò le immagini queste
grati di condivisione e quello che hanno
scoperto che vedete qui che non
riusciremmo a manhattan a portare tutti
a destinazione quando devono essa la
destinazione con un piccolissimo ritardo
diciamo uno due tre minuti al massimo ma
con il 40 per cento in meno delle
automobili che che usiamo oggi dei taxi
che usiamo oggi
ecco allora questo è il è stato il
nostro risultato scientifico
dall'analisi quando abbiamo iniziato a
lavorare sul progetto cooper non aveva
ancora lanciato
a seguito di questo progetto abbiamo
iniziato una grande collaborazione tra
il nostro laboratorio al mit e o per lei
come molti di voi probabilmente sanno
oggi coubertin permette proprio questo a
due persone che vanno più o meno nella
stessa direzione di condividere il
veicolo e google pur tra l'altro oltre
sono stato un grande successo per rubert
oggi vale parecchi miliardi di dollari
all'anno di infratel è stato anche poi
tra virgolette copiato o comunque ha
ispirato molti altri servizi simili da
parte di altri operatori tipo liste tipo
di in cina tipo o la tipo via eccetera e
quindi questo diventa interessante
perché come dicevo solo due viaggi che
al posto di essere dei viaggi sui
veicoli separati più viaggi vengono
combinati e questo vuol dire una
macchina in meno sulle strade
il che vuol dire meno ingorghi vuol dire
meno consumo di energia e anche meno
inquinamento nelle nelle nostre città
però questo è un esempio molto semplice
appunto di come partendo dai dati non
riusciamo a capire meglio la città e
partendo da questi dati possiamo farci
le domande le domande come dicevamo
prima di design vediate appunto come
trasformare una condizione esistente in
una diversa
proprio come diceva herbert simon e poi
da appunto da queste domande a trovare
anche soluzioni che possono lasciare il
6 in vari modi della città e questo è un
esempio fra tanti vi faccio vedere molto
velocemente se lavorando su altre cose
questo è un altro progetto pubblicato
molto di recente su snes share
[Musica]
faccio vedere solo alcuni secondi
orientato al mini moonfleet in questo
caso ci siamo chiesti qual è qui non
c'entra con la condivisione del veicolo
ma ci siamo chiesti qual è il modo più
efficiente per fare gli spacci per
assegnare le persone ai veicoli in un
futuro appunto in cui tutto tutta la
mobilità di una città si è fatta da
sistemi tipo macchine senza guidatore
tipo mobilità sud fondi mangi insomma è
di nuovo si scopri sono grandissime
efficienze questo tra l'altro questo
articolo è questo il brevetto che poi è
mai chi ha depositato partendo a questo
tipo sono la base dell'ultimo stata
cadiamo che abbiamo creato
quell'articolo su measure ecco allora
ecco io direi quasi inutili oggi mera
soltanto per mettere sul tavolo questo
un po come come argomento di discussione
l'argomento è proprio legato al design
dicevamo design nelle cessioni
percezione anglosassone di progettazione
e come questo nutrendosi di tante
discipline in questo caso le discipline
legate ai big ei tagli informatica
complex science la matematica e che ci
può permettere di leggere in modo nuovo
lo spazio che abitiamo in cui abitiamo e
di conseguenza da questa lettura di
ipotizzare nuovi nuove in qualche modo i
nuovi modi di progettarlo e di viverlo
fermare qui e spero la prossima volta di
vedervi tutti di persona buon giornale